a growing number of rohingya refugees
are making a dangerous journey by sea to
reach Indonesia on Monday a vessel
carrying almost 200 people landed in the
northern ache Province a day after
another boat arrived more than seven
hundred thousand rohingya have fled
their native country Myanmar in the past
five years amid a brutal campaign
against them by the military government
rescued and revived after surviving a
perilous Journey Indonesian officials
said these rohingya migrants washed up
on a beach in a wooden boat after weeks
at sea
39 of the refugees are being treated
with a medical infusion device and most
of them are dehydrated
officials are trying to determine if
this is the same group who are feared
dead after drifting at sea for more than
a month
the migrants say they hope Indonesia
will offer the chance of a better life
will give us their access the accounts
of Education
a day earlier another boat arrived
carrying almost 60 rohingya they say
they traveled not from their native
country Myanmar but from as far as
Bangladesh in the northwest
Bangladesh is where more than 700 000
rohingya refugees have lived in a
crowded camp for more than five years
they fled a violent campaign by the
Myanmar military which said it was
targeting Rebel groups human rights
groups say the rohingya are being
pressured to leave the camp a growing
number are again uprooting their lives
and trusting their fate to rickety boats
and the rough sea